did you ever get like into that world up
in humboldt county and uh absolutely
because that world is crazy man like
there's people who go up there and don't
come back down yeah not you know humble
it's uh humble's a beautiful place
there's great people up there there's a
dark side to everywhere you go but
humblets like they almost there's it's
almost like its own laws up there loki
like whoa you get in the hills it's a
whole nother story you know i can't wait
to that's why i've been waiting though
because a lot of my stories are coming
out in the series there's been some
crazy give me give me one crazy story
that that you could give us just just
give me one bro give me one uh well as a
trailer for the series well one story
was uh
i was up there with the buyer and we
went to uh to go by maybe like 100 ogs
or something like that and we drove up
to like a mountain so there's a gate on
the bottom of the hill
and my dude came down and grabbed the
bread was like i'll be right back cool
i'm sitting there with this buyer and he
drives up this hill
and we're chilling it's kind of hot day
and time just keeps going by it's not
coming back down i'm just like damn
looking at my watch i'm like damn what's
up go to my phone no service i'm like
[ __ ] a little nervous and dudes chain
smoking cigarettes i'm with the buyer
it's changing some of the cigarettes
he's like yo
go up there i'm like i'm not [ __ ]
going up there bro [ __ ] talking about
he's like go up there bro you get my
money this dude go up there i'm like man
i don't know what's up there i don't
know how far it is he's like you're
gonna go up there bro he's like it's
been about 45 minutes to do so i'll be
right back go up there like i'm not
going up there dude pulls out a gun
[ __ ] it back say burn i am trying to go
there bro but you need to go up there my
[ __ ] dude all right hop over to the
little shady fence start walking i
walked like 10 minutes bro and i'm
looking up this road it's just not
stopping i'm like
stripping sweat i come back down like
bro
i don't even see an end to this trail
i'm not gonna go i i walked for 10
minutes bro i'm [ __ ] sweating like
[ __ ] it's hot as [ __ ] i don't know what
to tell you like that [ __ ]
played us that [ __ ] drove up
the hill with my money and drove down
and left he's like he played this you
[ __ ] robbed me he's holding his gun
my bro i did not robbie starts honking
his horn honking his horn starts
tripping
i'm like bro just breathe we're gonna
figure it out it's all good like it's
all good it's all good bro it's all good
he's looking at me crazy honking his
horn i'm like this motherfucker's about
to shoot me for sure i'm about to get
shot and then also my boy comes down
that [ __ ] hill
i'm looking at this too and he's like my
bad bride would trim up a few more to
make it to even hundred i'm like
[ __ ] dude i started walking up
that hill trying to find him he was like
oh dude it's like a mile and a half
[ __ ] drive you wouldn't [ __ ] you
wouldn't have made it up the hill like
maybe
maybe if you were to walk forever you
know and i was like damn god damn bro
and the crazy thing about that story was
i took my little i took my little piece
you know me and my boy took my little
issue from the side when he went up the
hill he gave me my bag i gave it to a
little pretty [ __ ] to go ahead and dip
off
i opted and i hopped in a separate car
to leave i'm smoking a joint we're
driving and the dude was so stressed out
bro
literally i cannot make this [ __ ] up
we're leaving humboldt county there's
like a little area by um
some place called uh right when you get
into mendo um
but we're pulling off and this juice
pulled over bro
we passed them i'm sitting there smoking
and i've thought to get paranoid for a
second but i don't have anything in the
car but the weed i just took a couple
the chick had all my little cut whatever
i made she was already long gone but
they had this food pulled over dude
he had a bad day
he had a very bad and he had everything
on him he had 100 pack on him yeah and
they pulled him over yeah
did they end up he had a bad day i never
talked to him again brother i just wow
ghosts
what's crazy is like that's what people
don't know like in the wii game like a
lot of like if
middleman and [ __ ] is a great it's a
great little hustle it was good for me
you know back then but it just came with
it came with a lot of stress and you
know i think what happened to dude man
like he just
he was from out of town he was anxious
he just got profile leaving that place
and
i don't think they care about the
hunting pack i don't think they took
them to jail they was looking for money
them cops out there want money sometimes
bro just to shake you down because they
know what they know what you're doing
they probably took your [ __ ]
you know what i mean so
yeah man like
the game is not pretty bro how much
money did the guy go up the hill with
100 pack i mean [ __ ] what i don't
remember what the prices were back then
bro
100 pack og
i gave him like a
probably 40
probably 4
forty five hundred each back then you
know i mean
it's a lot of bread it's a lot of bread
yeah
yeah that's that's that's gonna shoot my
ass bro i seen his eyes
yeah
he's gonna shoot me and then the guy
comes down the mountain [ __ ] bro
hippie [ __ ] bro hella cool hella
calm collective we're sitting there
dripping sweat it's hot up there bro